[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to having
done this for 10 years now you realize
that over time different things become
nostalgic that's why I'm starting off
this nostalgia wean by asking the
question is this a thing is this Josh
[Music]
in 2004 Cartoon Network premiered an
hour-long special called the scary
godmother based on the popular kids book
by Jill Thompson and that's all I know
about it but you Millennials kept
shoving it at my face I have no choice
but to review it I have no idea this is
remember fondly not fondly or caused
flame wars tearing families apart a
strained part of me hopes for the latter
all I know is that people really want me
to review it so that's what I'm gonna do
I'm going into this completely blind
with no clue what to expect so let's
pause but the special I haven't seen yet
here this is scary godmother
as the credits roll we open to an
egg-shaped moon I'm open at fire this is
a Howard the Duck spin-off and we see
the film has an interesting style to say
the least
[Music]
[Applause]
okay am I the only one who thought her
boobs were about to shoot me
she moved like the t1000 nipples we're
gonna open fire
yeah by this point you're probably
thinking it's so nice they finally did a
kid-friendly version of The Walking Dead
games but this does create an immediate
problem and actually it can be compared
to the Walking Dead games both are
adaptations of drawn works which they're
trying to combine with computer
animation while still trying to simulate
hand-drawn lines you suppose this can
work I mean it's worked okay and other
projects but here's the problem
Walking Dead knew the characters in the
foreground had to have black lines and
the backgrounds had to be smooth and
blurred a tradition done for years so
characters in the foreground are the
focus but here the characters are the
ones who are smooth and blurred and the
backgrounds have the lines because of
this everybody looks like the Sunday
afternoon painting like they're
demanding a movement for movement it's a
little odd to say the least
Daryl are you a piece of candy yeah cool
huh kid you're scary just the way you
are you're sunken and dot eyes are gonna
haunt my nightmares this is Katie and
Daryl they're waiting on their friend
Burt to show up to go trick-or-treating
got enough room in your trunk for all
the can you will get do you have aa
sweet ride lame joke and weird segue
what sweet ride last but not least their
friend Jimmy shows up the devil and the
devil shut up here oh that almost made
me grow irises and my pupil Scott early
CGI is scary Jimmy's forced to bring his
cousin Hannah along who fully developed
eyes abomination on this world we become
monsters
surging forth
oh no you turn Hana into a
malfunctioning chuck-e-cheese
animatronic what the heck were you
shining that dump thing around for
flashback flashback are you anxious to
get outside with all the monsters
pumpkin huh we both know Katie will look
out for her
I trust that Darryl do not worry pumpkin
I have no frame of reference to what
you're doing now
your parents know how does this work
dingdong Darryl will protect you from
the monsters ding dong ding dong Denzel
already come on it's party quick answer
the door so Colin can perform don't
worry honey if you get frightened
Jimmy's promised to take care of you why
you come back to me like I should have a
joke I don't even know the hell just
happened okay here's the plan
we're gonna ditch Hannah the devil takes
many forms scare her and she'll run home
and then we can do what we want okay
she's kind of slow we did convince her
we were her parents and she might still
be under that assumption they agreed to
scare her by forcing her to go inside
the house they say is haunted why does
the animation in this always move like
it wants to eat me but the scary
godmother arrives to raise her spirits
[Music]
with that freaky entrance all she's
gonna raise as my blood pressure because
I turned down Magic School Bus to be in
this I totally could have been Miss
Frizzle she takes her on an adorable
kidnapping to her home apparently in
another dimension there we go what do
you think it's whimsically similar to
everyplace else she introduces hannah to
her broom maid Scully presumably voiced
by John Waters Oh bones bleached for the
party I'm just kidding Joe waters wishes
he could be in something this kid just
putting it out there guys booze like
half of our jokes
who are you Hannah this is mr. Pettibone
he's our official skeleton in the closet
I work in the closets of all the old
houses keeping their secrets the ones
who are brave enough to experiment when
it comes to Halloween night I love
nothing more than to roll the bones and
a good party roll the bones will have a
completely different meaning when you
get older there are so many of these
jokes guys the godmother uses her
incredible magic to make the place look
even more mildly impressive
as guests begin to show up oh if there's
any doubt it's that kind of party
just think of what your guest number one
smell is emanating from
I believe no down boy no more until
everyone else shows up
you'll be lucky if I don't bury a fever
in the backyard you can they said they
could bring Willie grace back so the
werewolf confuses Hannah for an actress
from one of his favorite shows it's as
funny as their sentence I just said this
is not a yeah why doesn't everyone come
up to the camera like their Slenderman
you don't die you're instead given the
short about how to make cracker
sandwiches because that's the next
logical step to take in this story the
Baltimore families show up and almost
confuse who the appetizers are for and
are help yourselves to the food oh how
adorable why don't you befriend one of
the people who is gonna devour you are
you a human
yeah you're just a kid
so are you do you go to school sure
that's cool these kids have their own
solar system what's with the orbiting
around them the party continues as the
werewolf seems to chat too much annoying
the vampires to my eyes Lukey cease your
chattering and sleep sleep what an empty
stomach but I oh good god he broke his
neck while also seeing Slender Man
actually the vampire just listened to
sleep however
Hannah's dead awake at the reveal of
their next guest
[Music]
the wife starts Garrard kids after hours
I'm gonna put in for overtime now he
joined the pterodactyls from Flintstones
and turning to the right and saying a
joke to nobody she learns to get used to
him though as the kids back at the house
are waiting really to frigging long to
not realize something is up what do you
expect when this is how they entertain
themselves door is ajar door is ajar
dwarf is a drill you stop that please
fasten your safety belts go out on a
limb and say he's tasted toilet water
why isn't she screaming yet oh it's
because she's turning into Annabelle at
this point nothing would surprise me now
what are we gonna do we've practically
missed Halloween I mean what are we
supposed to do go in and get her who
wrote us but we have no time for that
we have to vote on who we think should
be the leader of the group who wants
Bert for leader okay
Wendy's got two alien would be even
creepier if that was the face that's one
vote for everyone I demand a recount
that's still one vote for everyone
recount that's one vote for everyone
really get out that's one vote for
everyone okay looks like we're gonna be
here for a while folks I'm gonna go grab
a beer I suggest you do the same
[Applause]
[Music]
you
oh that was good anyway where were we
fast-forward so after all that essential
arguing they decide to just sit around
and do nothing you sure we're not
watching American politics back at the
party all sorts of amazing things are
happening like the vampires talk about
anxiety the werewolf / eats and they
decide to order pizza
they sure are putting the dead a dead
party aren't they
I'll phone this in like you haven't
already let's go check on the unlikely
possibility that there's more
interesting conversations with the kids
left Hanna in the spook house so much
trouble can't believe we left Hanna in
the spook house just said that she never
comes out I can't believe you left Hanna
in the spook house are you trying to
drive us insane will you stop it please
don't interrupt him I'm pretty sure he
was gonna say something about Hanna the
spook house and the believability of her
being in there how'd it go again I can't
believe it goes great with the multiple
rock-paper-scissors and multiple
shoutings of recount
oh that's missing is Doctor Strange
coming out say he wants to bargain what
is your goal you type pocket of madness
have you all gone crazy is there a limit
to how many times I can say yes this
better be followed by a funny moment or
I'm gonna shove a candy apple up
somebody's rectum
$200 in pizzas of course ya Kudo
No you get lucky looking for money to
pay for the pizza they sneak up on
Bugaboo to see if he said on any money
in a sequence I know can't be taken any
wrong way someone's been to too many of
Scully's parties so other than that mrs.
Lincoln how could you enjoy the show
strange enough that there's a Lincoln
assassination joke in this but the head
back classic followed up by crickets
ain't none of you know good comedy hey
Dracula tell your version of the
aristocrats after making friends with
everyone hand and the monsters decide to
go back home and get revenge on the kids
that left her we just conclude there is
nothing in the closet about him anymore
Wow not very often do you see a room
with six fireplaces
no wonder nobody lives in this place the
fire codes are shit Hannah pretends to
save them though as the monsters act
like they're afraid of her light here
Hannah where I ever see you again only
in the scars of your repressed memories
so that was the scary godmother I can
see why people remember it it's pretty
awkward clumsy and all over the place
but then again it's clearly meant for
little kids there is enough creativity
in the ideas and some of the designs
that I guess it's innocent enough
definitely won't hold any adults or
older kids attention but for younger
children it's totally fine not a classic
but a serviceable little special to show
tiny ones on Halloween take it for what
it's worth I'm the Nostalgia Critic and
nostalgia Wien has just begun
[Music]
[Applause]
can't believe he left Hanna in the spook
house
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out it's been a very painful month
for a lot of people as you can probably
guess once more I don't need to show any
cliffs because you've seen all the
terrible things they're happening in
Puerto Rico you know that they need so
much help right now and I know the past
couple charity shoutouts I haven't need
to show any clips because like I said
just mother nature has really been
brutal and so many people are suffering
for it so definitely go check out the
link below and see if you have anything
you can give because these people really
really need it and just so much
devastation is happening down there to
so many good people it's just not
deserved so if you can definitely go
click on the link even the smallest
amount can go a long way so definitely
go take a look and see what you can do
thank you so much again
you